former Vice President Joe Biden sounded
like a candidate last night as he
received a 2008 teen Freedom Award for
supporting civil rights so don't tell me
we have to accept where we are don't
tell me things won't change don't tell
me that we can't restore hope in this
country the former Democratic senator
joins a list of honorees that includes
Nelson Mandela Bernice King and John
Lewis we spoke with Biden at the
National Civil Rights Museum in Memphis
about a range of issues including the
dispute over voting in Georgia's
election in Georgia
a group of senior citizens loaded up a
bus to vote early they were told to get
off that bus do you believe that voter
suppression is under way absolutely
somewhere in the order of 77 in the last
couple of years a piece of legislation
introduced in state legislatures to
restrict the right to vote we should
have automatic registration there is no
no evidence in all the studies done of
widespread voter fraud of that being a
central problem in American electoral
process just not true in Georgia it's
reported more than 53,000 voter
registration applications are on hold
that's right and 70 percent of those are
African Americans surprise surprise so
do you believe there's an effort
underway absolutely positively without
question you've been out on the road a
lot campaigning for Democrats I know
you've said our democracy is under
assault what's at stake here
I think our basic American values are at
stake decency honor giving hate no safe
harbor telling the truth understand
there's something bigger than you and it
really is under assault and it is one of
those things that I think that only a
minority of the American people share
his view about that is so dismissive of
the basic American mores you know I mean
look what the world has seen lately
they see Charlotte spilling what he says
they see him embracing these dictators
around the world attacking our allies
they see in a situation where he talks
about he has a policy of literally
ripping children from their
parents at the border for God's sake I
mean it's it's not who we are as we walk
past the Lorraine Motel where Martin
Luther King jr. was assassinated in 1968
Biden says a lot has changed since then
and he remains optimistic about the
future of America I was asked by a
reporter well if he changed would you be
supportive absolutely absolutely but
stop this this phony populism which is
about I have a problems because of that
immigrant or that black guy or stop this
this naked nationalism which instead of
making us number one is make his last we
have the dumbest immigration laws in the
world the world laughs at us
what about civility in politics I mean
we remember when Michelle Obama at the
convention said when they go low we go
high I think I'm still right but the
Attorney General Eric Holder who may be
considering a run for 2020 said well
when they go low we kick them well you
know that's III respect the Attorney
General that's not my view I don't want
to get down in the mosh pit with these
guys it's not a place I want to play he
just dragged you and it's part of a
strategy part of their strategy drag you
down and talk about attack each other
personally I think the American people
are desperately looking for leaders to
bring them together not split them we
cannot function in this country without
a romantic consensus you are the
Democrats top choice to run against
President Trump injustice I don't think
that means anything I know but you think
about it you care deeply about this
country I know you do that's why you're
out campaigning not I don't think about
the polling data I think about whether
or not I should run based on very
private decisions relating to my family
and the loss of my son and what I want
to do with the rest of my life but I
don't think of it in terms of can I win
can I will I lose that's not part of the
calculation is age a legitimate issue it
is a legitimate issue sure it is and I
think people are gonna judge it if I
were to run I think the judgment my
vitality can I still run up the steps of
air force to my still
good shape am i do I have all my
faculties am I am i energetic I think
it's totally legitimate people ask those
questions President Trump says that
you're his dream candidate would be his
dream to run against you well I tell you
what well please we've got the cameras
rolling a just given me some wisdom
that's the worst time Joe Biden has ever
edited himself now that's not a
criticism it just is but no he must be
running if he's showing yes and it also
shows you know what your mom used to say
if you don't have anything nice to say
don't say anything at all because he was
clearly gonna say something and then
thought that better than we've got so
much more of this interview we'll post
it online and on my social media
accounts I asked him to about his age is
age a legitimate issue because he turns
76 years old next month so he talks
about his own vitality whether that's
part of the equation he also talks about
whether Democrats have an issue with
working-class white voters and his
response is really interesting okay
that's what it's wife Jill thinks about
a possible run as well but it's dr.
Biden saying yeah I know we can go on
the website but does age an issue for
him he says people yet he says it is an
issue and people can judge me by my
vitality it's just a number he's got
vitality for sure